you like to thumbnail this video I'm
gonna go in four rounds with Mickey the
no sing that's how I box that's why I
punched the way I do at the end of my
videos terribly Creed so Creed 2 is the
sequel to Creed obviously by the name
after the events of Creed 1 Adonis Creed
is at the height of his career but then
he gets a new challenger Victor Drago
yes that would be the son of Ivan Drago
the man who killed his father because
movies essentially the son of the man
who killed Apollo Creed versus the son
of Apollo Creed it's a revenge tale in
which killing would just be
unsportsmanlike and well nothing will
capture the lightning in the bottle that
was o Creed alright so that's
interesting that they're making a movie
about the son of a public crying to
reinvigorate rocky alright we'll see
when we [ __ ] that movie was awesome
but we could still trapped now Michael B
Jordan in the first Creed was great in
this movie also great actually has a
couple moments in Creed - I felt
surpassed moments in Creed 1 do does a
lot of emotions going on in here maybe
it's not as down to earth as the purity
of Creed was basically Creed 1 and Creed
- it's like rocky 1 and rocky 2 you can
argue the first ones - better made film
but damn it if the second one is not a
really good time at the cinema and a
really solid follow-up full disclosure I
actually prefer rocky to rocky 1 don't
shoot buddies Michael B Jordan is a
beast and he is great in this movie I
felt Sylvester Stallone was the scene
stealer in Creed 1 this one
it's Adonis Creed Michael B Jordan
himself who is the scene stealer one can
argue this movie's formulaic in the
sense that it does take beats from the
other rocky movies now Creed 1 was
essentially it's the same beat as rocky
1 just redone but while Creed 1 was
essentially rocky 1 creed 2 is a couple
different Rocky movies smashed into one
movie so they're that kind of keep it
fresh enough I guess change it up a
little bit I mean most any movie out
there is like it's like this movie meets
that movie like a Masters of the
Universe movie would be Star Wars meets
Lord of the Rings which makes me really
[ __ ] want a he-man movie where they
don't come to earth this one's like is
this Rocky movie meets that Rocky movie
so it's new they do a couple things in
here to be like alright we're gonna
change it up and tweak it a little bit
so it's not exactly the same beat from
the previous Rocky movie but it kind of
reminds me of when Vanilla Ice was
trying to describe the difference
between under pressure and Ice Ice Baby
it's it's the same I mean guess
technically you're right
but it's the same but the relationship
between the Donna's Creed and his
girlfriend I love that and nothing is
better to show the passage of time than
a pregnancy movies always try to show
hey passage of time and spend months
it's like it doesn't feel like months
are in this movie you can tell it's been
months because there is a pregnancy you
can see that so I appreciated the fact
that they used to pregnancy not only to
show time pass but also for Adonis
Creed's character gave him perspective
and I really liked how he showed Victor
Drago and Ivan Drago's life a bit more
and it might have shown more complexity
if maybe Victor dragos not the [ __ ]
his dad was well now he's an [ __ ] cuz
his dad's an [ __ ] we just kind of
forged in that world but I like the fact
that it showed a bit of their lives like
what's Ivan Drago been doing how's his
life been since rocky for I appreciated
the fact that they showed us more of the
life of the antagonists than I expected
to get in this movie man and he's not
the sympathetic character that a
genocide all maniac who snaps and wipes
out half of life in the universe now but
still I appreciate it they gave us a bit
of a peek behind the curtain with it the
flights are pretty solid too I feel like
there's more footage of the fights than
we actually got in this movie definitely
could have gone from more of the
fighting that's when the time passage in
the montaging starts happening you're
like I want to see more of the fight but
every Rocky movies always done that you
see the fade between the cards round 5 6
7 the fights were solid there's no one
fight as interesting as the one-shot
fight and Creed 1 but the fights were
brutal nonetheless like in the Rocky
movies rocky can just take slugs to the
face you're like he's not even dropping
really one of those punches most anyone
would be down for a bet but Adonis Creed
man those punches they hurt you can tell
you tell because Victor Drago is
enormous like wooden Adonis Creed
standing next to him he looks like the
mountain from Game of Thrones I was like
are they really the same weight class
are they really
I feel like this match is very unfair
this movie has an epic training montage
scene though love that montage no I
guess I'm a sucker for a really good
solid training montage this movie has
one guys in the end Creed - it was great
it's just like the solid sequel I want
to create - to be I will say Creed - is
definitely worth watching
definitely worth buying on blu-ray fact
after this movie I do get the feeling
it's like I don't know where they would
go for Creed 3 so I don't want to create
3 Creed 1 & 2 it's a solid Adonis Creed
story here but if this movie makes money
they're gonna make a Creed 3 and if this
director doesn't want to do it they're
gonna find one who does and they're
gonna run it into the dirt until Adonis
Creed takes on Tommy Gunn's kid or
something and it's gonna suck so just
stop here alright so Creed - have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]